hi the new season of shameless is
available only on Showtime catch the
exclusive trailer right
[Music]
[Music]
well you've been in meditation after the
death of your mother
acceptance resurrection enlightenment
you smoked half a pound of meth could be
brain damage too early to tell Frankie
Frank Frank Frank its st. Francis I like
being named for a saint you're the new
smart no owner yeah
have you met any of the other tenants
yet our merry band of deadbeats
your rent was due us first
you dog whoa whoa whoa
I need a sitter at tomorrow night
because I have a date she broke up with
you because of your drinking but if you
think she's the one then just tell her
you need six months to work the steps so
my Matthew I can't move it all at once
could attract cartel attention you
little [ __ ] you stole my map next
time I try to warn you against a plan
that was a terrible decision
maybe you will just [ __ ] are you
[Music]
Gallagher's are generally not normal
human
[Music]
suffer the little children to come to me
st. Francis
Monica died and then we put her in the
ground if you come anywhere near my
family I'll bury you with her
[Music]
Southside through-and-through
[Music]
you